in the academic study of religions we of
course always try to present topics from
a perspective that is
as neutral and unbiased as possible
but at the end of the day to be
completely unbiased
is impossible everyone has biases
everyone has a nationality a
gender an ethnicity a religious
affiliation that will inevitably
manifest itself in the way that we write
or
speak about any topic including of
course in academia
most of the time this stuff is
unconscious it's not something that we
choose to do
but it's rather just an inescapable
reality and if anyone in any context
ever claims to be
completely unbiased about a certain
topic
that's the kind of person you should be
very careful with but that doesn't say
that objectivity and neutrality is a
lost
cause rather the most healthy way to
tackle this
is to recognize that our background and
our personality will inevitably affect
the way that we
write and the way we speak and instead
of trying to neglect that or act like it
doesn't exist
we recognize it and keep a watchful eye
on it at all times while trying to work
through it and work against it perhaps
nowhere is this problem more apparent
than
in the western academic study of the
middle east
especially in the 19th and 20th
centuries there was a name
for this kind of scholar a western
scholar who studied the middle east
which was orientalist a person who
studied the
orient whatever that means but the term
orientalist and
orientalism has especially since the
second half of the 20th century
come to have very negative connotations
and instead
is associated with very problematic kind
of scholarship
problematic perspectives and narratives
about
regions like the middle east and is
something that academia is very actively
trying to work against
today so what is orientalism what is so
problematic about it and why do
commenters keep calling me
an orientalist
[Applause]
the word orientalism and the negative
way in which it is understood today
is very strongly connected to a book
written by the palestinian scholar
edward
saeed which was called well orientalism
published in 1978 this is one of the
most important books of the entire 20th
century
it revolutionized our thinking and
approach to studying the middle east
saeed and his book is one of the central
factors in western academia today
in part giving rise to what is known as
post-colonial studies and theories
and thus serves as part of the
theoretical and methodological basis
on which all contemporary research on
this topic is basically founded
now prior to scythe's book the word
orientalist wasn't necessarily a
negative one
orientalists simply denoted a usually
western scholar
who studied this thing called the orient
a word that really means absolutely
nothing at all but it's kind of akin to
what we refer to as the east
today not that that word is much better
but still
primarily we are dealing with studies
about the general middle east
and regions that were colonized by the
british and french
an important detail which we will return
to and make no mistake there were a lot
of
really great orientalists excellent
scholars and researchers they
laid the foundation for a lot of
important knowledge on these topics
and certainly a lot of these scholars
were well-meaning individuals who had
an appreciation for the cultures that
they studied but what
syed pointed out was that the
orientalist project carried with it a
lot of inherent problems
problems that these scholars themselves
didn't even realize a lot of the time
themselves
the thrust of science argument is that
orientalism
as it was at that point served as a tool
for colonialism as we all know the 18th
19th and 20th century
was a time when european empires like
great britain
and france had colonized large parts of
the middle east and
africa as parts of their empires this is
a topic that comes up a lot in my videos
because it's so important for all of
these discussions
the colonial period is a central part of
everything that is happening in the
middle east even to this day
and the orientalists especially british
and french orientalists
who study this region and these cultures
often did so in a way
that served to quote-unquote control
through knowledge the whole orientalist
project consciously or unconsciously
was often based on the assumption of a
european
superiority they of course operated from
a place of
power and in the process they
constructed and helped
strengthen narratives about the middle
east that were very
problematic condescending and often
inaccurate
first and most general of these is of
course the very construction of the
concept of the orient or the east
in itself the whole idea that there is a
somehow unified
quote-unquote east that has certain
characteristics and most importantly
stands in contrast to the opposite
concept the grand
west creates divisions that have been
very destructive and still remain to
this day
it is a very human tendency of course to
create in groups and out groups
by defining who the other is we are
simultaneously defining who
we are and this is kind of what's
happening here with
orientalism and and colonialism
that in these narratives by constructing
the east
as the other we are simultaneously also
creating this concept of
the the superior west uh standing above
this other of the east we still hear
people refer to this thing of the great
western civilization and
similar terms and this is very much
still a remnant of the
colonialist or orientalist project the
orient is the passive
other the object who lacks
self-determination and reason and who
needs to be taught or
saved by the active subject of the
civilized and rational west
recognize this kind of rhetoric it
definitely is very much still alive
today in various different contexts
we in the west kind of stand as the gold
standard of reason and development
who needs to help the inferior other to
become
equally sophisticated by often becoming
like
us this was the main criticism against
the orientalists
they even if they didn't mean it
themselves consciously they
contributed to this dichotomizing
worldview and this distinction between
east and west
which became a tool for the colonialists
to
have a kind of theoretical basis upon
which to
see themselves as superior and as having
the right to rule
over the irrational other that is the
east
the whole idea that there is a west or a
western civilization which is so often
talked about is very much a kind of
result of this kind of rhetoric by a
colonialist and orientalist
not only was this very general
dichotomizing the problem of
orientalism according to people like
saeed and his
his admirers but also the more
particular ways
that the middle east would be portrayed
in various ways by the so-called
orientalists
the so-called orient was often exotified
in various ways
both negative and positive people of the
region were seen as primitive
undemocratic and irrational a word that
is often used today is
backwards it's kind of a similar vibe
for example muslims and the religion of
islam was often portrayed as being
inherently violent
as being more prone to fundamentalism
and of basically being incapable of
changing ideas that still hold sway in
western consciousness today
the region's people were seen as being
sexually unhinged
it's women being heavily sexualized and
portrayed as very promiscuous
as opposed to the modesty of western
women
this narrative in particular of course
changed completely in the mid 20th
century and was turned upside down
suddenly western women were free and
those of the middle east were oppressed
and controlled
the important part is that we are doing
things right here and those people are
doing it wrong over there
a lot of the orientalist stuff has
survived into popular culture as well
for example some of the most classic
translations of the thousand and one
knights or arabian nights reflect this
very well the classic translation by
richard f burton is of the typically
exotifying and orientalist type
over sexualized highly problematic in
its portrayal of its characters etc
i have his translation of course so i'm
guilty of this but
still it's important to keep this in
mind burton himself
also exemplifies this archetype by
writing many travelogues about his
adventures in the east
perhaps the most famous of which being
his personal narrative of a pilgrimage
to al-medina
and mecca in which he retells the story
of how he went to the holy cities of
islam
under disguise as a [ __ ] abdullah which
you've got to give it to him is kind of
hilarious as is often still the case
today when the orientalists spoke about
the middle east
they did so through their own words and
through their own interpretations
now make no mistake many of these
scholars were brilliant
researchers and wonderful scholars
they often learned the languages of the
cultures that they
studied they often showed a great
appreciation
and admiration for these cultures was
not like they were evil
uh people with evil intentions they were
often well-intentioned
great researchers the people actually
spoken about
rarely get to represent themselves or
speak about
or present their own customs or beliefs
instead they
remain silent objects to be studied
instead of being
subjects that can speak for themselves
when edward said published his
orientalism
it shook things up pretty dramatically
it wasn't without its critics of course
many academics criticized it they felt
attacked
and they felt like saeed was portraying
a caricature of the orientalist
presenting a very one-sided image of
these
researchers these scholars but what site
was doing was not to attack the
credibility of these scholars
rather he was pointing out that
knowingly or unknowingly
the work of these orientalists often
contributed to the colonialist
narratives and the colonialist
project and for that reason needed to be
reformed or changed and that is largely
because of saeed and his book and the
subsequent development that the word
orientalist and orientalism has come to
have very negative connotations since
then
basically no one calls themselves an
orientalist anymore
and is associated mainly with
problematic narratives and problematic
perspectives on the middle east and
non-european cultures
in some circles being called an
orientalist is almost like calling
someone a racist basically but this also
shows you how much this
had an impact on academia as it stands
today
everything since the late 1970s when the
book orientalism was published
has basically been a response to it or
at least tried to incorporate those
critiques
into its its studies or its research
indeed the entire theoretical and
methodological field that is known as
post-colonial studies owes a lot to this
general
trend or this general movement the
institutions in europe and america
studying the middle east today do so
with these perspectives in mind
what this means especially in a
post-modern environment is that
researchers are self-reflexive
and self-critical that we have to
recognize our inevitable biases and how
our backgrounds affect what we write
and rather than try to hide behind a
veil of quote-unquote objectivity
we acknowledge these facts openly and
try to work around them this also means
that when discussing a certain culture
or a certain religion for example
people who actually belong to that
culture that religion is often given
more room to speak
why are we as outsiders to sit at a
distance and
explain to to you what these people over
here are doing rather than having those
people
actually speak for themselves instead
there is in academia a general movement
towards integrating non-european voices
into the
these kinds of contexts more and more it
still isn't perfect there is still
more to be done in that sense but there
has been a general
trend of moving more in that direction
indeed this was originally one of the
main
purposes of this channel i and this
channel can in a way be said to figure
within
a post-colonialist paradigm i always try
to work against the old problematic
depictions of cultures and religions of
the middle east for example and to
integrate the voices of people from
those religions
in how i speak about those religions
being trained mostly in a
post-orientalist environment
i am always kind of wary about talking
about cultures and religions other than
my own
which is after all what i mostly do on
this channel
but at the same time having this
critical attitude towards orientalism
does not mean that we disregard
everything that the orientalists did or
the accomplishments that they actually
achieved or indeed that white scholars
from europe or north america
aren't allowed to study non-european
cultures i see a lot of this kind of
rhetoric
in the commons and on places like
twitter there is a general tendency to
disregard any
western scholars talking about the
middle east as being orientalist
and therefore automatically having some
evil
evil agenda to spread misinformation
about the subject
but this dichotomization is also
dangerous as i said earlier creating
this kind of strong division between
west and middle east plays into the
colonial narratives of the orientalists
themselves
and if so-called western scholarship is
dismissed on the basis of orientalism
we create an unhealthy environment of
division rather than one where
mutual conversation and cooperation can
take place
if we do so then both inside and outside
voices can be allowed to intermingle
and help push forward our search for
knowledge which is what all this is
about in the end
this dismissive attitude towards
european and american scholarship
also fails to take into account that
things have indeed evolved since the
1970s
and that academia today is very
concerned with working against
orientalism as such that isn't to say
that the problems of orientalism is
rooted out or that they don't exist
anymore
all intellectual traditions always stand
on what
came before and is built on it this is
why it's so important for
scholars today to keep these things in
mind
to to know about the problematic
background of
some of these fields that we study and
to know about our own biases and our own
backgrounds
to always keep that watchful eye over
ourselves when we do scholarship
it's no surprise that a book like edward
science orientalism
is basically required reading for anyone
who enters
this kind of field there's a lot more to
say on this topic as always of course
but these are the basics
of what the word orientalism or
orientalist
usually mean it started out as a term
basically for
scholars who studied the so-called
orient which
usually meant uh the middle east but it
could also be a broader term but
uh mostly we're talking about people who
study places like the middle east and
africa those were the orientalists
and orientalism which wasn't really used
at that point but that could be
basically a term for that kind of of
research basically
but in the mid 20th century with
developments like for example
what i've returned to continuously is
edward syed's book orientalism
and similar developments the word
orientalism and orientalist
came to have a much more negative
connotation instead it came to be
associated
with very problematic narratives
problematic perspectives about the
middle east
that were often based in colonialist
narratives of european or western
superiority
which created a lot of problems both in
academia and in
really public discourse and public
discussions about this topic it's
something that still remains very
relevant even today so i guess the key
question in the end is
am i an orientalist then i guess that
really all depends on how you define the
word orientalism
if by orientalist you mean a person a
let's say a european person who studies
the cultures of the middle east or
africa
then i guess indeed i am an orientalist
even though i wouldn't choose to call
myself one for obvious reasons
but if we define the term more narrowly
as a person who espouses
problematic perspectives on middle
eastern
or african cultures someone who
contributes to colonialist narratives of
east and west and of western superiority
or whatever
or generally just inaccurate depictions
of the middle east based on um
orientalist perspectives
that's really not for me to say i'd like
to think that i try to be
in life and in these videos and in my
academic career
and indeed i am kind of trained to be
the kind of educator who
takes a critical stance towards these
kind of probably problematic aspects of
orientalism
and instead presents these topics in a
way that is
appreciative and nuanced and inclusive
but at the end of the day it really
isn't for me to say but rather for other
people
like for example you and the audience to
determine how good of a job i am doing
at that
i hope that you found this video
somewhat informative and that it gave
you at least a couple of things to
think about as always i appreciate
all of your support for liking for
subscribing for leaving comments
as always a special shout out to all of
my patrons
and even more special shout out to the
new saints subtag addis noshikonte
and to a lead for the very generous
donation
if anna wants to become a patron and
support this channel monetarily i will
leave a link to all of that stuff
in the description but really all of
your support
liking video commenting and subscribing
all that is
immensely appreciated um and i i
wouldn't be able to do any of this
without uh
all of you guys so thank you so much and
uh i will see you next time
[Music]